[Music]
why did you lie to me
okay let's find a question that's a
little easier
Todd and Julie Chrisley battled it out
during Monday night's premiere of the
family's reality show Chrisley Knows
Best we have the struggles that everyone
else has and we work through them as a
family but the drama isn't about their
recent prison sentence instead the two
are at odds as they prepare to move into
a new home for the third time in the
past year being married to Todd means
you're never going to call a place home
for very long but it keeps you young
right no it keeps me stressed and
unsettled and the only reason I agreed
to move into this new house is because
it was TurnKey I'm just excited to move
in unpack and be done yeah well that's
when Todd reveals he's actually gutted
the entire house stripping it down to
the studs you've got it
what happened to sprucing things up I am
what the heck happened Julie listen it's
like if you go have your eyes done then
you realize you need to have your neck
done and then you need to have an upper
lift and a lower lip people ask me all
the time what's the best and worst part
about having this show you know imagine
every day of your life going to work
with your spouse with your adult
children with your minor children and
with your mother-in-law just imagine
every day that being that being what is
your work environment of course the
season 10 premiere comes as Todd and
Julie are serving a combined 19-year
sentence the reality stars were
convicted for bank fraud and tax evasion
and they have until February 22nd to
file their appeal I think they're
optimistic and let me be clear I think
that optimism is well placed this trial
was riddled with heirs and we expect the
appeals court to see that but during
Monday night's episode there was no
mention of their legal blows I'm just
done with it I'm over it
I feel like we are at a stage of our
life where we need to find where we're
going to settle the episode ends with
Todd telling his wife he loves her and
doesn't want to fight I love you I don't
want to have friction with you I don't
want us fighting I love you but right
now I don't like you since their
conviction Todd and Julie have been
vocal about filing an appeal and have
been holding on to their faith
it's a very difficult challenge but
they're strong they're faithful and I
think they'll continue in in that Way
Forward
[Music]